Maya guides, K'in and Bor,
will lead us to the mountain.
And Mexican archeologist and climber Arcelia García
will help me explore it.
That's got to be the Red Mountain.
It looks like it.
Chak Aktun.
Chak Aktun, or Red Mountain,
lies around two miles to the northwest
of the archeological site of Noh K'uh.
I think I see some cormorants.
Are those cormorants right there?
Yeah.
Just like in the glyphs.
Can I pass you that rope?
Yeah.
Let's go.
Okay.
Looks like there's a little trail up here.
To tell the mountain.
Uh-huh.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
The ancient Maya believe that a powerful god
split a mountain with an axe,
releasing sacred seeds from which human life originated.
This is a powerful place. I can feel it in my bones.
What is this?
What?
You got to see this.
What is this?
Wow. Hole into the mountain.
Mountains are living, breathing things.
Wow.
I mean, a mountain with a hollow core.
This has to be the symbol
that's being referred to at Palenque.
You think this is what this is?
Sí.
The split mountain.
That's incredible.
Let's go.
Wow!
Hey, Albert?
Yeah.
There's another one over here. Another entrance.
It's got to be a connected cave system, right?
Right.
If this is the hollow mountain,
these tunnels could be the entry point.
We'll take one each.
You take those.
Yeah.
You have a radio?
When the ancient Maya discovered mountains,
like those described in their origin myths,
they became the center of their spiritual world.
We're going into a place
that's reserved for the gods
or the souls of the dead.
Hope the gods are with us.